[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mainfeld
und leute mir so ein lächeln ins gesicht
geschrieben wenn ich diese sonnenaufgang
ist er liebt diese leuchtturm hinter
unserer zauberinsel hinter unserem
extrem leisen portal schwert allerdings
will ich hier nicht vom eigentlichen
thema folter blenk meine lieben freunde
denn dieses bereits im titel
eingeblendet heute beantworte ich die
frage die sich glaube ich jeder von euch
hoffentlich vielleicht gestellt hat
irgendwann in den letzten folgen und es
geht einfach um das ende dieses
microsoft project ihr seht allerdings
auch schon dass ich hier gerade durch
meine kiste ein bisschen spiel brauchen
wir hier so ein paar sachen raushole und
ich benötige auch meine schere denn ich
habe bevor ich darauf eingehe zunächst
erst mal ein paar andere sachen zu tun
eine sache hat mit unserem schäfchen zu
tun ich weiß nicht wo das gerade
hingelaufen ist passiert vorne stand
oder so allerdings muss sich unser
schaaf erstmal muss das schon okay danke
dir
die sache ist dass ich mein schaaf
erstmal weiß färben muss damit ich ein
bisschen mehr weiße wolle bekomme denn
das ist ein ziel für die heutige episode
das wurde nämlich in die kommentare
geschrieben und zwar ist einmal unsere
camp hallo wenn man hier so jetzt kann
ich die scheren bam und zwar haben wir
unsere camping insel da ganz hinten da
sehen wir sogar das lagerfeuer und da
wurde nämlich dass hier geschrieben
luca du kannst ganz einfach wahrnehmen
und was ich auch noch machen wollte war
mir ganz ganz ganz ganz fix unseren
kompletten kloster nehmen
er fragt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich luca
das heißt jetzt wieder mit dem wir uns
bloß weil ich sie dann party
[Musik]
ich wollte das komplette los lukas
schilder vorne nicht mehr aus dem weißem
beton haben so wie es aktuell der fall
ist sondern aus kloster und so dass es
bei nacht richtig leuchtet bevor ich das
allerdings tue bzw wie ich das tue ihr
seht ihr jetzt in einer time lab denn
ich muss hier auch erstmal die schafe
wieder ein bisschen vermehren
die noch eine menge wolle holen für die
ganzen banner und auch das flugfeld
ändern also euch dann ganz kurze time
netz so freunde wieder her
[Musik]
was wollt ihr hier
ich bin erst mal ganz kurz das hier
zeigen
ich weiß man kann es jetzt gar nicht so
gut erkennen und das sieht irgendwie er
nach so ein bisschen popcorn oder mais
oder irgendwie was aus aber ich sag's
euch wenn wir dahin nachher stehen und
das hier sehen das geht richtig wild
aussehen bei nacht vor allem das habe
ich meiner tests welt schon getestet ich
weiß nicht was er für uns hier im
angebot hat blauen farbstoff schwarzen
farbstoffen dafür brauchen wir auf jeden
fall was auch für unser glas da hinten
da müssen wir auf jeden fall noch mal
mit ihm handeln die sache ist jetzt
allerdings dass hier die schäfchen
wieder ein bisschen wolle bekommen haben
der bürgermeister und auch unser anderer
schafft wir haben hier nämlich irgendwie
nur zwei stück oder ich finde die andere
nicht auch guck mal der andere guckt
sich einen sonnenuntergang oder was
machst du hier perfekt berger also von
dem brauch ich auch noch mal ganz kurz
die wolle die sache ist allerdings dass
ich nur 20 weiße wolle habe und auch
doch ich habe ein crafting table dabei
die sache ist jedoch dass wir insgesamt
36 weiße wurde benötigen für die weissen
banner und das kriegen wir definitiv
heute nicht hin von daher wollte ich
euch ganz kurz fragen werde sogar hier
auch werben
sogar drin crafting der bevölkerung oft
von daher wollte ich euch ganz kurz
fragen ob mir das eventuell bitte wieder
in die kommentare schreiben könnt dass
ich hier vorne ich habe auch was
vergessen
ich muss noch mal ganz kurz zurück ich
brauche nämlich noch zwei fichten
holzbretter für unsere mission dahin mit
den weißen bannern die sache ist jedoch
dass
ist so nice aus
mit diesem leuchtenden wohin
guck mal wie geil das aussieht mit
diesem leuchtenden lost blue cross
dahinten vor allem mit der spiegelung
und nur hier wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr wild ich weiß ja wie hier vorne
noch ein bettchen drin aber das wäre
perfekt dann können wir nämlich mal ganz
kurz eben schlafen gehen ich brauche
zwei fichten holzbretter für unsere
banner situation an der camping
situation das hat er hier wie du hast
einen neuen beruf bist schon experte du
kannst es sind viele macht auf dieser
insel die wirklichkeiten sind ihr fragte
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich mensch luca im
titel steht herr endet das projekt was
ist phase wie gehts wie stets wie
sieht's aus
ich weiß ich werde doch gleich darauf
eingehen die sache ist jedoch dass sich
zuvor das erstmal auf der anderen insel
hier ganz kurz machen möchte und dafür
habe ich mir hier gerade jetzt mal 50
holzstufen gekauft da oft aus meiner
liste genommen
die können jetzt nämlich einfach hier so
hin packen und dann können wir jetzt
hier können wir jetzt hier in weissen
banner daran platzieren hier und hier
und genau das gleiche müssen wir dann
auch nochmal für die andere seite machen
denn jetzt sieht es wirklich aus wie ein
zelteingang und wir können jetzt hier
einfach mieten sehen nicht was dahinter
ist und sind dann plötzlich drin mit der
kuh dann geh raus du passt doch safe
hierdurch dekaden von ihnen können wir
jetzt hat auch nicht richtig rausgucken
das ganze heißt das gleiche soll auch
noch hier auf die andere seite jedoch
brauchen wir dafür wirklich noch ein
bisschen mehr wolle eine kuh offenen
dach alter die andere ist sie mittendrin
also gut
ihr kriegt das hier auf jeden fall hin
mittlerweile alles ich werde noch mal
ganz kurz eben weil ich jetzt gerade
genügend fichtenholz buch mit dabei habe
auch das hier ersetzen dass ich mich
besser aus wenn das dann so ist anstatt
dass wenn hier der bahn ist dann noch
ein zaun da drüber und zweitens wird die
sache ist jedoch dass bevor ich jetzt
auf die fragen eingehen die ihm ihr
stellen durfte
unter einem community poster.de nicht
raus gehauen habe die letzten tage das
gegenüber ganz platzieren doch mal eben
die poller mitnehmen
die duftet mir kommentare stellen ihr
konntet ihr konnte mir fragen stellen
nicht kommentare stellen
die konnten wir fragen stellen in bezug
auf dieses projekt hier irgendwas was
euch interessiert was ich beantworten
könnte und habe ich zehn fragen des
screenshots auf die ich gleich eingehen
wollte
die sache ist jedoch dass sich das ganze
machen wollte während wir endlich mal
wieder auf erkundungstour gehen
aufgegessen
das haben sich einige immer wieder
gewünscht dass ich mal wieder ein
bisschen rumlaufe denn in der letzten
zeit war die meiste zeit so dass wir
sachen gebaut haben wir haben allerdings
auch richtig viel in mir kriegt also
gerade mit dem mit der strandhaus will
er da vorne damit unserer insel da
hinten und generell einfach was wir aus
dieser welche schon erschaffen haben
auch mit den denkmälern dahinten das ist
ja wirklich extrem da ist aber gut meine
lieben freunde prioritäten setzen ich
möchte wirklich ganz ganz fix auf
erkundungstour gehen deswegen werde ich
ganz schnell mal eben einige smaragde
mir hier holen um tatsächlich dann mal
eben rüber zu geben
zu unserem bibliothekar denn erstmal um
natürlich zu schauen ob er unser lang
erwähntes reparatur buch im angebot hat
aber auf der anderen seite kommen die
haben alle keinen platz mehr hat
rückstoß verbrennungen stärke er hat
wirklich nichts anderes ich brauche auf
jeden fall ein namensschild und das hat
etwas damit zu tun was hab ich hier und
platzwarte schmeißen
nein
erst einmal den hut
[Musik]
ich kann das nicht weg bringen
das wird schon von alleine gehen oder
kann ich mir die klappe aufmachen
[Musik]
okay gut ich lasse mich immer in ruhe
ich habe auf jeden fall meinen namen
steht das benötigen nämlich wie die
heutige wieso denn hier wurde in die
kommentare geschrieben luca so meine
freundin für balu ja ist doch egal also
dass er trotzdem fragen haben ja aber
dass ihr befreundet sein
ist mir egal ich werde auf jeden fall
jetzt eine freundin für badoo suchen und
dafür dort hinten durch das los lukas
schild durchfahren denn dort hinten
befindet sich unsere winterlandschaft
und deswegen da wir dort halt auch in
alu denen wir also den hund die mir
gerade auf unserer insel haben gefunden
haben habe ich mir gedacht das ist
vielleicht eine ganz gute idee und
vielleicht auch einen zweiten hund zu
finden vielleicht sogar jemanden aus der
gleichen blicke rudel reißen das rudel
resultieren gehen' rudel rasse rudel
rasselbande rudel aus der gleichen
truppe da auf jeden fall rudel
[Musik]
was sind diese komischen obsidian teile
ihr manchmal meine lieben freunde wir
wollen uns nicht auf ewig gold blog oder
ob sie die anteile konzentrieren ist
aber trotzdem geil dass ich da so ein
paar sachen mitten im konnte abstauben
konnte so einen goldenen abschied noch
nie einen goldenen apfel rosen projekt
ist mir aufgefallen aber den gold
bekommen auf jeden fall gut gebrauchen
vor allem was trading irgendwann an geht
die sache ist jedoch dass ich euch ja
gesagt habe haye steht ein paar fragen
und darauf würde ich jetzt sagen gehen
wir jetzt auch mal direkt einem wir sind
ja jetzt ein bisschen auf erkundungstour
ist wenn ich eine richtige
erkundungstour wir waren eigentlich
schon an der ecke da hinten aber ich
werde auf jeden fall wieder ein bisschen
in unsere heimat verlassen ein bisschen
aus der box ich habe ein paar sachen
mitgenommen den kompass zum beispiel
wieder nach hause zu finden wären also
unser reisebett ganz klar ein bisschen
holz habe ich mitgenommen dass hier
falls wir im internet gehen sollten
eisenwaren pfeile essen genug knochen
natürlich selbstständig für den hund bzw
die hündinnen ich möchte eine weibliche
ich möchte dann noch so ein pinkes
halsband geben und so und ich habe mir
auch schon namen überlegt
beziehungsweise habe ich dann in den
kommentaren gesehen
das werde ich euch bleibt
[Musik]
ich will erfolg
die ganze zeit sind hier ändern wenn auf
meiner insel welt
[Musik]
yahoo da kann ich hab an bord kaputt
gemacht ich wusste ich dass mir das mit
einem schlag mit dem schwert abbauen
cristina loi das funktioniert wirklich
und ich hatte ja immer so 20 mal drauf
aber gut ich weiß gar nicht warum meine
welt so durchzechte ist von
irgendwelchen endermann und klappern und
alles mögliche spiel auf stufe normal
das kann doch nicht sein dass die
tagsüber schon solche ändern wir nie
rumgammeln aber gut wir halten jetzt auf
jeden fall die augen auf und sind auf
der suche nach einer neuen hündin für
unsere welt ich weiß dann auch hier
vorne ganz erinnerungen hier vorne bin
ich ja mit einem brötchen drüber
gefahren und so das war ganz nice da
hinten haben wir dann glaub ich gefunden
und zum wald da würde ich auch sagen
schauen wir jetzt direkt mal nach einem
weiteren hund jedoch würde ich sagen
starten wie direkt mit der ersten frage
die ich noch vor dem sonnenuntergang
beantworten möchte und zwar ist die
frage von geely hat er schreibt nämlich
oder sie schreibt nämlich was war dein
längstes video in minecraft bevor du es
geschnitten hast was ist das ist schon
geil
die sache ist
ich feiere irgendwie jedes minecraft bio
aber gut freund ich würde sagen ich
schlag erst mal ganz kurzen ein bettchen
da vorne neben der lava auf da ist es
zumindest auf immer wieder die
polarlichter oder später voll vergessen
dass wir in unsere schneewelt immer die
polarlichter am boykott ist mein gott da
schlafen wir doch nicht als ja ein
waldbrand
was geht denn hier jetzt plötzlich ab er
fackelt er die halbe welt ab oder was
aber schon mit dem polarlicht an
wir legen uns hier so hin wundervolle
aussicht aber gute freunde
was war das längste video jetzt mal auf
die frage einzugehen
ich glaube das war 1
wo ich eine menge im netz das war das wo
ich in der höhle war und wo ich direkt
die folge gestartet hat mit einer teils
von wegen ich paulo kurz ein paar ärzte
ab dann muss sich die times kurz stoppen
weil meine apple watch gesagt habe stehe
man bitte auf besitzt schon wieder eine
stunde hier eine aufnahme dann bin ich
danach gekommen mal gerade ganz kurz
gucken nur ganz kurz kommen
[Musik]
denn bogen fallen lassen ja den brauche
ich nicht chapman stärke breitreifen
[Musik]
jetzt konzentrieren muss mal ganz kurz
also ich wollte erst mal ganz kurz
schauen ob wir irgendwo eventuell direkt
hunde sehen dann können wir die mission
nämlich schon direkt beenden
ich sehe hier jedoch leider keinen hund
von daher laufe noch ein bisschen weiter
nach rechts in die richtung und jetzt
gehe ich mal auf die frage ein und zwar
glaube ich wirklich dass es diese höhlen
folge war ruhig erz abgebaut habe und
danach dann die thermik gespendet habe
dann hab ich wieder erz abgebaut wieder
mit einem lätz eingeblendet also das war
es auf jeden fall und ich glaube das
waren dreieinhalb stunden oder so um den
dreh oder vier stunden ansatzweise das
war wirklich brutal
ich erinnere mich gerade dass wir hier
vorne glaube ich balu gefunden haben
weil ich am horizont das dorf entdeckt
habe und dann habe ich gesagt kommen
nehmen wir den hund direkt mit und daher
würde ich sagen kraxeln wir hier an der
seite des berges jetzt einfach mal
runter und schauen ob dort hinten noch
einige hunde aus der rasselbande
gewartet haben dass wir sie abholen
zuvor werde ich hier doch mal ganz kurz
schauen ob mir ein bisschen kohle haben
denn kohle wirklich ich habe es immer
mitgenommen und ihm habe ich dann gesagt
er braucht man ja sie überall einfach so
babys warten
wir brauchen wirklich mal wieder ein
bisschen kohle und das halt das ding
hier vorne kommen schon wieder raus wir
haben kohle hier auf jeden fall am start
also während ich die kohle abbaut
ich mag keine blöcke dabei
[Musik]
wir haben hier hinten allerdings auf
kohle meine lieben freunde also erst mal
ganz kurz alles hier ausleuchten freuen
aber ungebetene gäste kommen während ich
hätte allerdings die cola bekommen
direkt zur nächsten frage von kiri thode
allstars war fragt er wie viel zeit hast
du schon in eine insel investiert
ich weiß nicht ob man sowas irgendwo
sehen kann irgendwo in den statistiken
oder so wenn ihr da genauer bescheid
wisst dann schreibt mir gerne unten in
die kommentare dann kann ich das in der
nächsten folge euch mal zeigen
ich würde allerdings tippen da wir jetzt
ja schon bei 70 folgen oder so sind und
ich in jeder folge safe mindestens eine
stunde hier drin war dass ich auf jeden
fall mehr als 70 stunden allein in
dieser welt hier verbracht habe wie lang
ich insgesamt bereits minecraft gespielt
habe weiß ich allerdings nicht weil ich
mir minecraft auch schon häufig neue
runtergeladen habe wenn man irgendwas
kaputt gemordet wurde oder in die neue
version oder neuer pc also da sind die
werte glaube ich nicht so ganz
zuverlässig 12 34 möchte wissen wie
schaffst du es dir so schnell zu
überlegen was die tiere bzw dorfbewohner
zu dir sagen und wie kannst du dir dann
merken was sie sagen sollten also im
schnitt die sache ist dass das wirklich
eine frage ist die mir sehr häufig
gestellt wurde und zwar ist das einfach
spontaneität
also es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich mir
vorher denke dort könnt ihr jetzt das
sagen deswegen gehe ich jetzt mal dahin
meistens bezieht auch einfach dann
darauf was die dorfbewohner oder die
tiere mit denen ich halte viele wie die
sich dann danach bewegen ob die sich
dann vielleicht mal im kreis drehen oder
irgendwo hoch laufen oder runter laufen
oder irgendwohin gucken also da geht es
mir eigentlich meistens drumherum das
ist immer relativ spontan und dass ich
es mir dann merke während ich dann
später im schnitt sitzes entweder das
wenn ich schon weiß okay danach setzte
ich dass ich dann kurz sage für mich im
schnitt so was ich da dann eingeblendet
haben möchte oder ist auch schon wieder
kohle ist oder hier ist irgendwie gar
keine monster
ich will zusätzlich vorher rufen dass
wir gleich welche kommen aber
die meiste zeit ist es wirklich so dass
ich mich wirklich einfach merkel und ich
meine gerade wenn ich beispielsweise in
der letzten oder vorletzten folge mit
dem hund also mit balu geredet habe und
irgendwie gesagt habe ja alles was ihr
hier hört dürft ihr nicht für bare münze
und dann hat halt der huntgeburth welt
geschafft
dann kann man sich das ja auch schon
denken was dann gesagt wird wir haben
hier hunden auch wir haben hier schon da
habe ich schon lava ich wollte nur kurz
kohle ohlendorf ein messdiener höhlen
expedition oder was sie es aber
vielleicht auch gar nicht mal so
schlecht denn wir benötigen wirklich mal
wieder ein bisschen ärzte und waren ja
auch schon lange nicht mehr in einer
höhle deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier
wirklich mal alles mit ich hoffe nur das
gleiche nicht irgendein krüger von der
seite kommt ihr merkt auch schon die
musik hier unten ist sehr fröhlich dafür
dass es eine höhle expedition oder
definitions folge bei minecraft mit luca
ist denn es soll eigentlich gar keine so
eine höhle expedition folge sein und ihr
seht ja es kommt fast keine monster das
ist jetzt keine krass furchteinflößende
würde hier und ich will mich auch auf
die ganzen fragen konzentrieren von
daher kommen wir auch direkt zur
nächsten frage von tp 7 hast bevor das
projekt mit max weiter zu machen zb als
staffel 2 da ist generell das ding oder
wurde mir auch geschrieben wie lange
geht das projekt noch um die frage geht
hier eine ähnliche richtung das war auch
eine frage die mir sehr häufig gestellt
wurde
die sache ist dass ich mir wirklich
überlegt habe wie es mit dem projekt
weitergehen soll das habe ich ja zum
ende der letzten folge schon gesagt dass
ich mir so ein bisschen gedanken gemacht
habe wie es weitergehen soll ich war
schon immer ein youtuber der gesagt hat
hey wenn wir irgendwas nicht mehr spaß
macht oder wenn ich irgendwie bock auf
veränderungen habe dann mache ich das
und genau so ist es auch bei diesem
projekt mir macht es noch spaß
allerdings gerade aus dem grund weil es
mir so viel spaß macht möchte ich
das ist dann aufhören wenn es am
schönsten ist und das hört sich jetzt
vielleicht so an als wird das projekt
jetzt morgen enden oder so allerdings
habe ich mir gedacht dass es wirklich
100 folgen lang gehen soll
also noch 30 folgen das heißt drei
viertel des projekts habe ich schon mit
mir zusammen durchgestanden tatsächlich
das ist kein eisen und danach werde ich
mal schauen was ich mache also ich habe
auf jeden fall bock danach irgendwie
entweder vielleicht eine neue welt
anzufangen oder vielleicht ein
multiplayer let's play wenn mein gott
auf einmal hier zwei auf einmal alter
die ganzheitlich keiner und jetzt auf 12
wenn ihr ihn welche ideen haben
irgendwelche wünsche gegen welche
anregungen und wenn ihr euch denkt
mensch hat er schon wieder zwei auf
einmal
[Musik]
jetzt wird auf da kommt noch einer ist
auf jeden fall gerade hier ein bisschen
stressig also erstmal ganz speziellen
holen sagt ein einheits check sind auf
jeden fall perfekt
und jetzt mal ganz kurz eben wieder in
den kampf angesagt
st
mal gelesen ich glaub's nicht
leuchte erst mal ganz kurz aus bevor ich
mir zunächst der sowohl auf die frage
eingehen der spinne
wir haben hier eine ich wollte einfach
nur kurz kohle holen gehen allerdings
möchte ich wie bereits gesagt jetzt
keine traurige musik einblenden oder
eine furchteinflößende horror musik wie
ich sonst man den höhen expedition
machen sondern ich möchte wirklich
einfach auf die frage eingehen
also ja ich bin relativ offen was das
ganze angeht das einzige was ich mir
bisher wirklich überlegt habe und dann
bin ich auch fein mit mir und ich glaube
da werden sich die meisten auch denken
hält macht sinn des projektes wegen weil
ich will das jetzt auch nicht unnötig in
die länge ziehen und hier einen gong 2.0
projekt machen mit 1000 folgen und keine
ahnung was meint ihr schon wieder zack
und hier und auch noch eins aber das hat
sich selbst das ist eine richtige
skelett höhle hier wieder
was geht denn hier ab müsste hier zack
und hier unten auch noch ein set wenn
wir hier keine diamanten finden das
projekt ihr okay ich bin voller hass
gehindert ich bin voller pfeile auf
jeden fall
ich möchte einfach nur kurz pole holen
gehen hält das kannst du doch wieder
nicht ausdenken was ich sagen wollte war
dass ich das projekt die nicht unnötig
lange die länge ziehen möchte ich möchte
sie keine 1000 folgen raushauen
ich möchte dass das projekt dann endet
wenn es cooles wenn es passt und ich
glaube wir eine menge geschafft und wenn
wir sagen folge 100 ist das ende
dann passt es eigentlich ganz gut
alabama david alaba spieler von bayern
münchen was ich sagen wollte war dass
ich glaube wenn das 2
ich glaube dass wir alle happy sind wenn
das projekt noch folge 100 endet und
dass wir eine menge geschafft haben und
stolz auf das ganze sein können was wir
hier erreicht haben und daher macht mir
direkt mit der nächsten frage von ambra
und zwar schreibt die wie fühlt es sich
an wenn du dir überlegst das jeden tag
tausende menschen deine videos anschauen
ist jetzt zwar nicht direkt auf
minecraft mit luca bezogen sondern
generell auf meine videos allerdings
fühlt sich wirklich sehr beängstigend an
sage ich mal in einer positiven art und
weise bin ich bin wirklich und ich
glaube ich komme so nicht rüber in
meinen videos aber ich bin nicht der
extrovertiertes der menschheit bin ich
sogar stunden in der höhle hier
angekommen
ich bin nicht der extrovertierte mensch
oft auch ein bisschen schüchtern und ich
kann endlich mit aufmerksamkeit nicht so
gut umgehen ich sehr ungern auf bühnen
ich merke ja schon ich nehme nie
irgendwelche rutschig bruder
ich nehme nie irgendwelche tv anfragen
an oder schauspiel sachen weil ich so
was einfach nicht kann ich möchte
einfach wir sitzen meine videos
aufnehmen und eine schöne zeit mit euch
haben im nord das gleiche mache ich ja
seit zehn jahren und in meiner freizeit
treffe ich mich ja gerne mit meinen
freunden die aber auch alle nichts mit
social media oder schauspiel oder
irgendwas zu tun haben
deswegen ist es für mich sehr
beängstigend wenn ich immer die zahlen
sehe dass ich irgendwie weiß ich nicht
die viele klicks ist aktuell sind wenn
sich 30 millionen leute monat nicht eine
videos angucken
darüber darf man sich keine gedanken
machen finde ich und darüber möchte ich
mir auch keine gedanken machen weil ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt genau wüsste
dieses video hier bekommt eine halbe
million aufrufe und ich spreche gerade
zu 500.000 leuten dann würde ich hier
nicht so entspannt sitzen wie es gerade
tour in irgendeinem schlaf shirt also es
fühlt sich sehr beängstigend an hast du
überhaupt noch lust zu aktiv minecraft
zu machen weil du das ja schon so lange
machst das ist eine sehr gute frage
tecchannel tecchannel 05 keine ahnung
ich crazy na ja da haben staat habt ja
auf jeden fall klar ist kann ich das
spiel mittlerweile in und auswendig
obwohl nicht jetzt wirklich nicht der
beste bin weiß ich auf jeden fall wie
das funktioniert und weißt du das ganze
spiel funktioniert und liebt das spiel
ja auch die sache ist allerdings dass
minecraft in meinen augen ein spiel ist
wie gta mit open world oder wie
fortnight oder auch mario kart das ist
immer was anderes ist es ist halt keine
story die du irgendwie spielt sondern
jedes mal wenn du irgendeine neue
welt anfängst oder wenn du mit freunden
spielt dann ist es wieder was ganz
anderes
es ist immer irgendwie neue spiel was
man spielt und deswegen ist glaube ich
minecraft ein spiel was mir nie
langweilig wird es wurde mal langweilig
für mich an in einer zeit wo minecraft
gerade verkauft wurde an microsoft und
die das irgendwie ich sogar gemacht
haben finde ich aber mittlerweile macht
nun wirklich sehr viel spaß und ich
glaube das sieht man auch an diesem
projekt hier david hat als nächstes die
frage gestellt die sich glaube ich jeder
irgendwie schon gestellt hat und zwar
wie lange geht das projekt denn jetzt
wirklich ungefähr noch und das habe ich
euch hat zu beginn schon so ein bisschen
beantwortet ich möchte die 100 folgen
voll machen und ab dann wird es keine
weitere folge in dieser welt minecraft
mit luca geben ich muss jetzt mal ganz
kurz ihre neue spitze machen das hört
sich jetzt ein bisschen hart an glaube
ich wenn ich sage ja es wird schon zu
viele folgen geben und abfolge 100 ist
ja alles vorbei aber ihr könnt euch auf
ein bisschen darauf freuen denn auf
jeden fall werdet ihr nachfolger 100 den
zieht bekommen wenn die welt von vorne
spielen möchtet ihr werdet auch diese
welt hier bekommen ich werde die
hochladen so dass ihr auch hier in
meiner welt reingehen können und
irgendwas weiter bauen könnt wenn ihr
möchtet oder irgendwas umbauen wollte
doch noch etwas dazu bauen wollte
irgendwas anders machen wollte was ihr
euch bei mir nicht so cool fanden dann
habt ihr auf jeden fall die möglichkeit
zu also ich finde wir sollten jetzt
nicht uns in trauer wiegen und sagen ja
blöd dann ist es halt vorbei sondern uns
auf bin
das neue 100 danach freuen was es dann
halt geben wird wo ich mir noch gedanken
machen werde bzw
durch das ja ganz gerne zusammen mit
euch mir überlegen also wie gesagt wenn
die ideen habt für staffel 2 was euch
interessiert soll es multiplayer sein
soll es wieder single player sein sollte
vielleicht eine geordnete welt sein also
mit irgendwelchen mods drin hier in
minecraft soll ich
einfach genau alles gleich machen wie in
diesem projekt mit einer neuen welt und
neue sachen die wir uns vornehmen ohne
irgendwelche ideen habt dann schreibt
mir gerne und in die kommentare denn das
ist halt die sache wovon dieses projekt
wirklich immer gelebt hat und zwar von
euch und euren tipps von euren
vorschlägen was sich bauen kann und
euren anregungen kommentaren fragen und
ohne euch wäre dieses projekt halt
wirklich komplett beschützen gewesen
deswegen bin ich auch euch da wirklich
sehr sehr dankbar für aber um ihn auf
die frage zurück einzugehen lieber da
wird das projekt mit biss folge 100
geben da wir gerade irgendwie bei folge
70 73 so um den dreh sind halt
dementsprechend noch so 30 folgen da
jeden zweiten tag ein video kommt mal
mehr mal weniger noch so circa zwei
monate flammen fixieren möchte wissen
hast du vor den villiger namen zu geben
wie beispielsweise paul brunhilde oder
so eine sehr gute frage ich habe ja
bisher nur schon halten namen gegeben
schon ist allerdings leider von uns
gegangen
also schauen dass schaaf wenn jetzt ein
neues steht hier das hat auch sogar noch
nicht mal einen namen und ich habe
pepper namen gegeben und der crew
allerdings obst allerdings leben die
meisten von themen ja leider nicht mehr
es ist vielleicht eine sache die ich in
der nächsten staffel dann machen kann
sofern wir denn eine nächste staffel
haben oder was ihr da möchte
schreibst du auf jeden fall mal auf ich
habe schon ein paar ideen oh gott ich
dachte gerade hier geht's hoch jetzt hab
ich mich schon wieder verlaufen
ich habe auf jeden fall schon ein paar
ideen für die nächste staffel geht es
hier lang ich glaube hier hoch ging es
oder nicht gerade komplett verloren
ganz kurz meine bruchsteine hier ich
habe auf jeden fall schon ein paar ideen
was man umsetzen könnte in der nächsten
staffel minecraft mit luca und da freue
ich mich wirklich schon extrem drauf
geht es denn jetzt die lange hier geht's
hoch meine lieben freunde so haben auch
gleich den ausgang gefunden per du hier
vorne lang gelaufen und dann sind wir
auch gleich wieder im berg und sehen
schon wieder die polarlichter
ich finde es so schön es wirklich wenn
wir irgend jemand sagt ich dachte
schrieb das blatt
wenn wir irgend jemand sagt minecraft
ist nicht schön was ist das dann der gar
ich begebe mich nun allerdings weiter
auf die suche nach einem hündchen nach
einer freundin über lud das war das
eigentliche ziel für die heutige episode
und da will ich sagen machen auch direkt
weiter mit der nächsten frage und zwar
hättest du früher gedacht dass noch so
viele menschen unterwegs
viele menschen und leute 2 max hier
erstmal prioritäten setzen
wir haben hier vorne eine kleine hündin
und sie läuft vor uns weg nicht dumm wie
möchten sie noch nicht so richtig mit
dem knochen
[Musik]
hast du lust bekommt aber nur als schwul
und ja das könnte auf jeden fall also
wir nehmen er sie hier auf jeden fall
mit und bewegen uns dementsprechend
zurück in richtung unsere insel
beziehungsweise einrichtungen mehr läuft
jetzt hinter mir her ja sie läuft auf
jeden fall hinterher ich habe mich ja
auch extra ein bisschen verrottetes
fleisch hack ich gerade nicht
weggeschmissen soll sich ihr das leben
kann so jetzt kann ich allerdings
schmeißen
ja nächste frage meine lieben freunde
hättest du früher gedacht dass noch so
viele menschen minecraft feiern beide
weight liebe ich deine videos erstmal
danke für das kompliment freut mich sehr
einmal zu hören
nein um die frage klipp und klar zu
beantworten nein hätte ich nicht gedacht
ich weiß dass minecraft auf jeden fall
ein bisschen im hype ist gerade durch
dream und durch die ganzen multiplayer
server sachen wo sich viele youtuber
zusammentun und dadurch risiken pusch
bekommen die sache ist allerdings dass
ich niemals gedacht hätte wirklich
niemals dass sich so viele leute für
einen ernst stinknormales minecraft
vanilla singleplayer let's play von mir
vor allem interessieren einem youtuber
der lange zeit selber kein minecraft
gemacht hat da bin ich wirklich sehr
dankbar darüber dass das ganze projekt
so gut und krank bei
fast allen angekommen ist und damit
gerechnet hätte ich aber niemals da wir
hier hinten jetzt allerdings schon durch
unser los locos schild durchfahren ich
das wirklich extremen als mit ihren
leuchtenden vor allem bei nacht die
lamas rastete völlig aus
da wir jetzt allerdings jetzt schon
wieder zu hause sind würde ich auch
sagen kommen wir nun zur letzten frage
für die heutige riesige fragen folge ich
werde mal ganz kurz hier das büdchen
abbauen ohne dass sich unser hühnchen
hier so ein bisschen verletzt da haben
ja alle immer angst wenn ich schon so
ein bisschen rum schlage dass ich hier
wieder nächstes tier tötete das brot
kommt allerdings natürlich wieder
zurückkehren jedoch erst wenn unser
hündchen hier wirklich aus dem wasser
wieder rausgekommen ist das ist jetzt
der fall perfekt und jetzt nehmen die
kleine auch einfach mal mit wir haben ja
unsere namensschild auch da vorne das
muss jetzt einmal ganz kurz zu dem namen
ändern was ich mir gedacht habe was ganz
geil wäre was den kommentaren stand
jedoch möchte ich nun die letzte frage
beantworten und ich finde die passt auch
ganz gut ob es hier zum ende des trading
aus versehen also erst mal ganz kurz das
namensschild hinnehmen und jetzt
danke jetzt zur letzten frage meine
lieben freunde und zwar kommt diese
frage von jetzt wieder an und zwar fragt
er oder sie ich weiß es nicht in
euphorie wird die folge 100 bei dem
projekt falls es eine gibt eine special
oder xxl folge die gleich darauf ein ich
zeige euch allerdings erstmal wie die
hündin heißen wird und zwar balance ja
gar nicht kenne das ist eine total
überteuerte luxusmarke und das wurde mir
die kommentare geschrieben da bei lablue
heißt und balenciaga ist ähnlich wie
balu aber irgendwie auch weiblich mit
diesem am ende dann wäre ich auch
weiblich wir haben sie hier auf jeden
fall schon das heißt wir können sich
hier valencia denn der musste aber
eigentlich auch bei lou heißen dann
nehmen wir dich sagen nehmen wir mal
ganz kurz wie smaragde raus und
verwenden hier noch mal kurz ein paar
ich glaube das passt dem gibt 21 stück
sogar sein namensschild aber bevor wir
wirklich irgendwie ein suchen müssen in
welchen ruinen oder keine ahnung was
macht auf jeden fall sind das für unsere
marke dafür vertreten hier mit unserem
bibliothek karten babor typ wir haben da
ist es perfekt nehme das namensschild
mit freunde die werkbank beziehungsweise
diese teile die brauche ich auf gar
keinen fall
jetzt laufen wir mal ganz fix eben noch
schnell zurück zu balu und ich kann die
letzte frage beantworten und zwar ja die
letzte folge wird die längste folge des
kompletten projekt und zwar möchte ich
in dieser folge geht das nicht
dann bleibt erst mal ganz kurz hinter
ihr steht schon wieder voll nehmen der
sprüchen die mich schon wieder so lange
auch schon allerdings xl folge hier
gerade die sache ist dass ich auf jeden
fall in der letzten folge alles noch mal
machen wollte was dieses projekt
ausgemacht hat also ich wollte mit
meinen tieren reden
ich wollte in die hölle gehen ich wollte
in die höhe gehen so richtig mit ambient
mit mit der mit der musik kommt zwar nur
auf balou und hier haben wir am ball ins
jahr gegenüber fußball ins jahr ihr
perfekt einmal hinsetzen sahen wir die
beiden hier angesprochen wir für beide
cdu nun erhöhte aber das ist schon mal
ganz suite mit einem roten bändchen
hierbei ins yagaloo mit einem blauen
finde ich sehr nah ist also es wird auf
jeden fall ein bisschen was special
mäßiges geben
ich werde alles einfach nochmal machen
ich werde vielleicht einem ort
installieren ist wird eine xxl folglich
wird lockt eine stunde lang gehen also
freut euch auf jeden fall noch folge 100
danach mache ich dann auch erstmal zwei
wochen youtube hause dieses projekt mir
wirklich kompletten letzten schlaf
geraubt genauso wie diese folge
wahrscheinlich auch wieder im schnitt
ordentlich lange dauern wird von daher
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gern einen daumen hoch
unter dem video abonniert neuen kanal
und vor allem klickt auf die glocke
damit in neue videos nicht verpassen
übermorgen geht's weiter schreibt gerne
in die kommentare was ich machen soll
ich bin schlafen balu dass das letzte
wort
[Musik]